confusion also about coronavirus testing
is widespread across this country
California with a population of about 40
million has 18 labs processing test kits
the state has tested just over 1000
people and confirmed 159 cases our own
dr. David agus is in Los Angeles good
morning to you
Marty Michelle health and human services
secretary Alex azar just told us there
is no barrier for doctors to get tests
that they need for patients what's been
your experience well let's be clear he
said there's no barrier from a public
health official to have a patient tested
there certainly are barriers for doctors
across the country to get patients
tested and I've seen it and I'm getting
calls you know both from governors and
from doctors across the country various
states it's easy other states it's very
hard so there certainly is not ability
to get tested on a same-day basis across
the country at the present time dr. what
impact has the delay in available
testing had on how we contain and
mitigate this virus you know I had a
patient last night I'm they call me the
CEO called me of the company and said
they just tested my employee and it's
gonna be five days til I get a result
back how do you do a containment when it
takes days to know the answer of what's
going on and so there was a piece in The
New York Times yesterday about in
Seattle they started testing people but
the government said your test isn't
approve you can't do it even though
there were positive tests and it delayed
actually quarantine II people are
keeping people contained and it enabled
some of the spread that happened in the
city of Seattle David what are you
telling people about when they should
get tested well right now I say if you
have mild symptoms stay home self
quarantine the system can't handle large
numbers of tests and I don't want people
waiting in waiting rooms at ers and at
hospitals so to limit the testing out to
the testing is readily and easily
available so the administration says
that millions of tests will will will be
sent out by the end of this week what
happens when folks get them I mean who
should be tested and how should they be
distributed well realize what a test is
it's looking for a hundred of the 30,000
letters in the virus who two genes in
the virus and the government is sending
the template for those hundred letters
the problem is is that all of the other
reagents which is actually to take the
RNA out of the virus the genetic
material out of the virus it was
announced yesterday that reagent is
short in the country so even though the
government's sending out tests we're
missing some of the reagents and so what
we need now are all the components of
the tests and people who can actually do
the tests out there so we can test the
right people the more we test the more
knowledge we have the more we're going
to be able to stop the spread of this
virus in South Korea they're doing
10,000 tests a day and they've been able
to stop the rise of the virus and the
virus they're started when it started
here in the United States David I want
to get a quick question in on our
frontline workers health care workers
who are now being told they can actually
wear a different kind of face mask after
the initial kind that was approved as
apparently running short on supplies
what do you make of this expanded
recommendation that a master that wasn't
ok is now ok we had a national stockpile
of n9t fast which are the 90-95 mats
which are the better fitting masks that
can actually filter most of the
particles in the air and what happened
is we never replenished that after the
last supply was dwindled down and so we
don't have enough in the country now you
see nurses unions today announced that
they're they're protesting the fact that
we don't have the right protective
supply for the frontline which are the
medical personnel out there this is a
big problem we nee certainly need a
national strategy to deal with these
supply chain issues because they're
happening over and over again and we
have to protect everybody dr. David agus
thanks David